well folks it's the most wonderful time
of the year the time of the year when
every reviewer and publication has
released their year-end list and here i
am left feeling as if i'm late for
releasing my year-end list at the end of
the year there's been a lot of great
music this year a lot of projects i'd
like to cover on this list i've narrowed
it down to 30. the first half i'll talk
about are going to be honorable mentions
and that's so i can include some
projects that aren't exactly albums in
the traditional sense and those 15 won't
be ranked and then i'll give you my top
15 in order so yeah let's jump right
into it so for my 15 honorable mentions
in no specific order i'm going to start
with brockhampton's roadrunner new
lightning machine
it's not my favorite record from them
but it's very polished and it sounds
like they're nearing the end of their
life cycle as a group and i think this
is a great entry to kind of close things
out next i'll say turning wheel from
spelling
[Music]
this is a really cool fantastical
project and i love that spelling is
spelled wrong next in the honorable
mentions from john mayer is sobrock
[Music]
i think he did a really good job
inhabiting a specific time in headspace
with this album so good on you mr mayor
next one might be a little controversial
but lord solar power
[Music]
am i the only person on earth who likes
this album and not melodrama probably
but yeah i really like it next album i'd
throw in here would be casey musgraves
star-crossed
it's not on the same level as golden
hour but there's a lot of good stuff on
here i just really like her style so i
feel like i'm going to enjoy pretty much
anything she makes next honorable
mention i'll go with is by the time i
get to phoenix from entry reserve
[Music]
very unique glitchy project from these
guys definitely fallen into a more
specific sound than before i like where
they're going i like this a lot i can't
wait to see what they come up with next
the next one i'll mention it's two
projects but it's westside guns hitler
wears hermes eight sides a and b
[Music]
an absurd double length project like
this has to go on honorable mentions for
me but it's fantastic westside guns
really mastered his craft there's a
baseline level of quality present on
here and all of his releases that just
kind of makes me upset that he's got to
release so much speaking of griselda the
next album i want to mention is blue
bannisters from lana del rey
good on her for releasing two albums in
one year that's no small feat i'm sure
you could find fans on either side but i
prefer blue banisters i think it's a
really good work on there next up we've
got an ep and it's the aptly titled our
extended play from bibadoobe
it feels appropriate for me to put eps
and honorable mentions and this is one
of my favorites of the year it's short
sweet and highly addictive check it out
if you haven't i actually realized in
post that i forgot one of my honorable
mentions and that would be zarface and
mf doom super what okay
okay
when this was in my mid-year i didn't
expect it to make it to the year end but
honestly it's a very competent doom
project and one of my favorites from
zarface so yeah it's it's sticking
around next honorable mention i want to
get into is slater's troubled paradise
there's a lot of interesting hyper pop
aspects to this album but at the end of
the day it's just really danceable
really good music next up would be book
of changes from novelis and dixon hill
[Music]
i reviewed a novelist project earlier
this year he is a criminally
underappreciated detroit rapper i didn't
hear this one until early december so
i'm glad i waited on making this list
because this is some of his best work
and if you haven't even heard of
novelist great now is the time to jump
in next up is one that i see high on a
lot of people's list it's bo burnham's
inside
again now obviously i love the songs on
here but it's not a traditional album so
it's got to be an honorable mention for
me i would say to go check out the
special on netflix if you haven't
already but let's be honest you're here
you're on the internet you've seen it
next up would be mikedeans422
[Music]
he's best known for his work with kanye
but mike dean's solo stuff is really
impressive so just throw this hypnotic
album on and lose yourself and the last
honorable mention on my list is going to
be the alchemists this thing of ours
alchemist put out two this thing of
rsvp's i only have the first on vinyl
yet waiting for a release of the second
which i'm going to be all over but man
alchemist is one of my favorite
producers and he continues to be one of
the most prolific in hip-hop these eps
are short but they feel like parties of
some of the best underground rappers
around well we're talking about
underground rappers so probably not a
party just to kick back now we get into
the top half of the list my top 15 which
is ranked we gotta start with at number
15 um do moktar's a freak fig team
[Music]
to me there's nothing like finding an
album you love from an artist you've
never heard of bonus points if it's from
a country you've never been to i love
the way this album sounds and i love the
way it feels if that makes any sense at
number 14 i've got the war on drugs i
don't live here anymore
i was the late adopter of this band and
for that reason i think i enjoy this
album a lot more than a lot of fans did
this band just always strikes a great
balance between triumph and feeling and
nostalgia if you haven't heard any of
their projects i don't know where that's
the best place to start i don't know
what else to say it just rocks number 13
is going to be an evening with silk
sonic from silk sonic
[Music]
i love this project it's a great
non-stop energy from front to back and
even though it's over in about half an
hour it makes you want to come back for
more bruno mars and anderson park are
both incredible artists in their own
right and i can't wait to see if they do
anything else together because yeah this
thing bangs at number 12 i have isaiah
rashad with the houses burning
[Music]
isaiah rashad is an acquired taste and
frankly no other rappers sound quite
like him but if you are into the vibe
that he presents
this kind of thing is really good it's
quite a bit more laid-back than his
previous projects but yeah i settled
into it quite nicely and i still enjoy
this a lot at number 11 you just have to
picture me holding the vinyl because it
doesn't arrive until march but it's
pray for haiti from makami
[Music]
again artist i hadn't heard of prior to
this year and i love this project blown
away by it and man the album cover still
my favorite of the year i just i love
this project it continues to be in the
rotation for me at number 10 i have a
beginner's mind from sufjan stevens and
angelo de augustine this is the thing
about people
i really enjoyed angelo's album back in
2019 and there's a video on youtube of
him and sufian performing a song from
that album
[Music]
i loved that i never expected we'd get
an album from them as a duo but boy am i
glad we did because yeah this thing
rules at number nine i have mood valiant
from hiatus coyote
[Music]
it really has been quite some time since
they released a project but i love the
sound that these guys have it's neo soul
there's a bit of jazz it's just very
warm and relaxing and i love this
project number eight is gonna be dope
game stupid from bruiserwolf i'm an
instrument i'm an instrument nobody
sound like this i don't like this
bruiser wolf of course is on bruiser
brigade danny brown's label and those
guys released a bunch of albums this
year all of which were pretty good but
nothing stood out to me like dope game
stupid bruiser wolf is right in that
nobody sounds quite like him it's a
super unique style of rapping that can
be jarring at first but once you get
into it man his one-liners are unmatched
at number seven i have the self-titled
album from laura stevenson
nothing creeps like measure time it's a
really fantastic mostly acoustic
singer-songwriter album i've been
listening to laura stevenson for a few
years now and i feel like this is the
most engaged i've been with one of her
albums and it's one i'm going to keep
playing for years number six is another
vinyl i haven't received yet and what
i'll have to put in in post but it is
bo jackson from boldy james and the
alchemist
again
i've already said my piece about
alchemist being one of the great
producers of our time but man bo jackson
there's a perfect match for him he's got
such a laid-back
ice cold delivery
and this is their second album they've
done together i don't know which i
prefer between this and the price of tea
in china but the work they do together
is just something else now we're in the
top five in the top five i gotta kick
off with home video from lucy dakis
[Music]
yeah i'll admit it i hadn't listened to
her music prior to boy genius and the
team up with fifi bridgers and julian
baker what a special album this is very
introspective very open and raw
emotionally a handful of my favorite
tracks of the year from this project
it's not one to be missed that number
four for me is tyler the creators call
me if you get lost
[Music]
that was personally one of my favorite
10 second reviews i did this year
and i love this project it is all over
the place in the best way it truly
embodies the globe trotting spirit but
also the spirit of mixtapes which is a
combination i don't think i've seen
before tyler's an artist who's
constantly evolving and exploring new
spaces and i really love the direction
he took on this project i can't wait to
see what's next at number three for me
is going to be jpeg mafia's lp
and i got to go with the offline version
jpeg mafia is a really unique voice in
hip-hop another one that i can't get
enough of his last project all my heroes
are cornballs set such a high water mark
for me and this one doesn't quite get
there
but it is extraordinary as well if you
haven't listened to it yet i recommend
you go on bandcamp and get the offline
version it's name your price so you can
put in any number maybe ten thousand
dollars and just get the album for
yourself trust me you're not going to
hear anything like it anytime soon
number two for the year is going to be
cassandra jenkins an overview on
phenomenal nature
[Music]
i found it pretty early this year and
it's continued to sit with me i keep
going back to it it really is like
therapeutic the songs are emotionally
healing and the music itself is
comforting too i mean there's a track on
here that's pretty much just nature
sounds plus a saxophone this was another
one that took me by surprise so yeah
there have been a lot of great albums
this year from artists i never knew
existed but i can't wait to see where
they continue to go into the future last
but not least number one my favorite
album of the year kanye west donda donda
rather my version of the album
[Music]
if you pay attention you should already
know this i did a video on this some
people brought up a good point is that
even fair to call that your favorite
album if you have to tinker with it i
don't know the answer to that question
but i did it here and it improved my
enjoyment if i didn't tinker with it
would it be my favorite album of the
year probably not but kanye gave us the
tools and he gave us the tacit approval
to make our own versions to do with it
what we would and i
have not stopped listening to it i
cannot stop listening to it i think i
have a problem so there you have it
those are my favorite projects of the
year mostly albums as for favorite
tracks of the year i like doing a top
100 songs and i've got that playlist
available on apple music and spotify
links should be in the description below
you should already know 30 of the songs
i've used them in this video but there's
plenty others from albums that didn't
make the list a lot of great music and i
hope you guys have a chance to check
that out and let me know what you do
enjoy i'd love to hear from you you know
what were your favorite albums of the
year what really moved you this year
it's crazy to think that i didn't even
have this channel a year ago 12 months
ago i didn't even exist and now there's
tens of thousands of you who are
watching this and that just
it's really cool thank you guys for
sticking around the 10 second reviews
will be back next year but yeah i hope
you guys had a good restful holidays
spend some time with your family and
let's keep it going
[Music]